we're here with environmental lifestyle
expert and my dear friend Danny Theo who
just made us just a delicious summer
linguine I
would be my new favorite recipe because
it's so lemony so now he's gonna teach
me and Ross because we were working with
beautiful edible flowers and then it's
like Danny literally anything you give
to you you can find dual and triple
purposes for so I love this tip and
trick from you and I want to learn it
will you teach us so I call this one gay
MacGyver I love gamer
flowers or you've got flowers in the
yard you know it's a beautiful time to
pick wildflowers we're gonna make these
we're going to take boring candlesticks
the flowers and little like stems and
things the trick is to find things that
are kind of delicate and thin and flat
all you need is are you ready a brush a
cheap brush a tea light candle that's
your glue when you lay it okay I was
gonna ask the glue because of course I
feel like I'm gonna make this thing
explode with some flammable material
just because the wax when you paint with
the melted wax that acts as the glue
you're kind of decoupaging yeah so all
you do is you take a pedal okay and you
kind of just take a little bit of the
melted wax put it where you want it you
stick the pedal on top it's got a stick
just like that and guys
just be careful of the Open Flame you
don't want to stick your um you know
your brush into the open flames and just
be mindful you don't want to get lit
project
darn it what I had to pick some big
petal I overachieved I went I went I
went too big you know they say go big or
go home that's okay because like what it
basically does is that when you see it's
like you just go around and around if it
doesn't stick you just move on to the
next pedal I mean that's the beauty of
this is that all of these things are
inexpensive you can do whatever pattern
you want very meditative I mean I'm
frustrated but it's meditating
I'm mad at myself for not being better
at this to stop it nobody can hold a
candle to you drew oh Rossi I love you
we just reaffirmed how much we love Drew
and look what I made while I did it look
at that see Ross yours is really really
beautiful and and I do love this and I
will be doing this oh yes I will all
right I loved how Danny you were like it
kind of looks like a Satanic ritual
but it's really really optimistic yeah
but it's like it's like a mother earth
kind of pattern and the trick is like
you want to go on top of the candle
that's the glued and then you put the
pedal on top but the more wax you use
the better it is you can't be too messy
with this you can't be too sloppy
because the end result it dries down so
quickly
and just but that's beautiful really
yeah I like to say let me see I'll be
honest let me see here
I love texture you know bossy doesn't
like it no it's cute I want mine to come
out like this it will it will with
practice all right and time it does help
to like just sort of just keep applying
and just stop self-flagellating during
the whole process and it's you're
learning so much and then if you want
yes we're done with these we can light
our candles if you'd like oh yes oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I want to see this
I have some real basic bee candles at
home and they are about to get a new
treatment all right ready here we go oh
oh yeah oh he's over there are the
Beauties like this one along with me and
then we can this I have to say was so
much fun
and look how beautiful
Drew you know what it's not so bad right
it was it was a real rough Journey but
you got there look at it you know what
just like the rest of my life I love you
guys so much thank you
[Music]
foreign